hi everyone at the network State
conference my name is Ryan Johnson and
I'm the founder of culdesac culdesac
Tempe is a car-free community in Arizona
that's open right now for people to move
into so we announced our project in
November 2019 right before the pandemic
and it got a lot of attention because I
think that people have realized how much
we've built our cities for cars and I
actually live there myself and we
started Construction in in 201 21 and
the first residents moved in earlier
this year this project it's it's for
rent and so uh we had people that uh
that that are signing leases so our
residents don't park on site and so what
instead of owning a private car our
residents use a portfolio of Mobility
options we're right on the light rail
and keep in mind that KAC Tempe it's not
its own City it's not on the edge of the
city it's it's right in the middle and
we're right on our own light rail stop
so the ways that people get around are
light rail ride sharing electric bikes
and now autonomous vehicles and so we're
starting with build culdesac Tempe it's
a th residents and it works within the
context of Tempe and the broader Phoenix
area yeah so think of the site it's 17
acres and it's a rectangle and uh in the
northwest corner is a light rail station
and we start building there and we built
the key retail building so there's a
restaurant there's a grocery store
there's a coffee shop there's a gym
there's a co-working space there's a
bike store and we have eight micro
retailers and there's also residential
units built into those buildings we've
talked about how almost everyone loves
walkability and this is not just being
this is not something that's anti-car
this is about uh it's more fun and
better to get around with a portfolio of
options and there's a lot of Trends with
the TA where the Tailwinds are strong
even in the last few years with electric
bikes autonomous vehicles and these are
going to shape our cities and they're
going to have profound impact
on real estate and it lets us build new
designs and that's what cesac is about